Should tech platforms be liable for what
users post online? In 1996, Congress said
they shouldn't. Section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act protects
platforms from lawsuits based on
user-generated content. A person who says
they were harmed by material posted
online has to go after whoever posted it,
not the platform on which it was posted.
But with controversy swirling around big
tech, some are arguing that CDA 230
should go away. That would probably be a
mistake. Without CDA 230, platforms might
either ban user-generated content, or
refuse to moderate it because of the
risk of being treated as an author or
publisher. Lawsuits could swamp their
small competitors. If we could go back in
time, it might have been better to let
common law courts determine the rules. A
common rule of no liability for
platforms would have been better than
immunity given by Congress, because that
will be a political football forever. CDA
gave us the huge, vibrant social media
environment we've got today, even though
some bad actors get a pass. We should
probably keep that sensible liability
rule rather than experimenting with
something new.
What do you think about CDA 230? Should
Congress reform, it repeal it, or leave it
in place? Let us know in our poll. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like
scholars to cover in 60